citizens of the reject Nation we're
going to talk about something that came
my way and I was like really really well
leave a like John how are you I'm
excited to find out what we're talking
about how are you good good I asked John
hey did you hear what Antonio Banderas
said about Zorro nope well I found the
clip and I'm gonna have John react to it
looked it up I was like you can't be
serious and he is and I want to get my
thoughts on well don't read it John
don't read it I'm not saying anything
don't read it don't read it nothing and
it's from comicbook.com Antonio Banderas
was interviewed asking about returning
to Zorro The Mask of Zorro one of my
favorite movies I wanted to ask you
about this in the film The mantle of
zorros passed down from Anthony Hopkins
to you and recently there's been this
surge of Legacy sequels so would you
entertain the idea of completing azoro
Trilogy coming full circle returning to
Zorro and passing the mask down to
someone else
yes I would I would yes
why not if they call me to do this or I
would do what Anthony Hopkins did in the
first I do love that movie yes give the
torch to somebody else is there a
specific actor working today that you
think would do a great job
Tom Holland what yes
spark too you know yeah why not
like I think Tom Holland's a great actor
ever since he came out on the scene when
the impossible he's been like knocking
it out of the park because a lot of
movies like you know the devil all the
time and I've heard he's screaming
Cherry I haven't seen Cherry but I hear
he's great in it even Uncharted as
Charming as he was I I could only see
Tom Holland I could not see just Nathan
Drake so the idea of him playing Zorro
is the car I know right you just know
how he would be yeah anything goes in
the other guy yeah
yeah
but I would want him to try to be a
Spaniard I wouldn't want him try to be
Mexican I would want him to try to do it
put on a little mustache and everything
I'd want him to go all out you just name
dropped Zolo uh yeah Blue Beetle guy
yeah yeah he's the up-and-coming Latino
actor he's like that's a perfect pick
I didn't even think about that he's
already Suave to knock where to uh you
know there's like a bunch of other
Latino actors that could play Zorro Sean
like with zamo that ship hasn't already
sailed I guess the thing that like
surprised me with the San Antonio
Banderas throwing it into the ring and
you know in a day and age where when
people put stuff out there that makes
Studios go well maybe
[Music]
I know he's trying to get this green lip
from this interview and I'm saying
please God no it's hard to it don't do
it don't do it I know you inherited the
mantle in the movies from Anthony
Hopkins who's a white guy so it
canonically in this version it could
work but Captain Zana Jones who is
relatively unknown as I remember seeing
the trailers I didn't know who she was
that movie probably introduced me to her
and I thought that she was an actual
like Latina actress come to find out
Michael Douglas's wife
eggs for even whiter yeah I'm perplexed
I mean I'll gladly welcome a new Zorro
movie I mean mask of Zoro is great I
even like Legend of Zoro and Legend of
Zorro too like like there's quality but
also I fear that bringing in a Tom
Holland will turn Zorro into the kind of
like uh the Paul WS Anderson Three
Musketeers I don't want it to be you
know I think you know when there's
obviously the other side of the crowd
that hears something like this and we're
like well they they keep casting ethnic
people for my white roles well then let
the Latin actors keep the Latin roles
actually there's very few
if we're gonna gender if we're gonna
race Bend every character and Gender
Bend every character then we got a white
wash and uh man washed these rolls I was
thinking about this I'm looking at
Antonio Banderas how old is Antonio
Banderas he's gotta be this I should I
should have looked this up beforehand
I'm unprofessional let me see here
62. look at him this is a recent
interview he does not look 62 years old
beautiful in a day and age where you
have actors who you know like like what
the what the interviewers posing here of
Legacy characters returning you know
like a big surge of that was things of
like Sylvester Stallone returning for
Rambo and Rocky and Schwarzenegger never
giving up the Terminator or Bruce Willis
under the never-ending Die Hard sequels
yeah
you know Joe's five yeah I'm looking at
Antonio manderos I'm like why would you
need to pass down the mantle you look
great the guy's in a mask
you can pull this off easily no problem
like you wouldn't need to pass down the
mantle is what I'm saying like it's a
good Trilogy idea but if you wanted to
just come back for it I'm like you don't
need to pass it down man you could
easily still play Zoro you could do one
more movie and pass down the mantle in
part four forever
forever yeah get Chris Pratt yeah
perfect he's the guy you do part three
which is the return of Zorro yes and
then you do part four Zorro forever yeah
and then uh
the order of the five swords and doesn't
he have a kid does Zorro have a kid yeah
doesn't he passed the battle down
there is one pitching this idea no he
and Tom Holland were on the set of
Uncharted one day just like having a
conversation having a chat and then they
probably talked about Zorro for five
minutes and then Antony's like I know
what I must do I thought it was funny I
just thought it was like a really funny
story it is it's just it's like it's not
even that he's the white guy he's the
whitest guy he's like the whitest guy
Nathan Drake is like no whiter it's like
there's no one whiter and we know Tom
Holland so much also from like the
billion dollar movies he's in but also
the countless interviews he's like a
meme in and of itself you know yeah just
be the most distracting casting like who
would believe this if they passed it
down to specifically a Caucasian guy
like the characters Caucasian that would
just cause a whole new storm yeah I
think it would and I feel like you know
Tom Holland we were lucky with
Spider-Man where it's like I'm okay most
people don't know him so he can at least
be known as that or Tom Holland but now
you know it's like it's going to be so
distracting like Zorro is a mantle that
I think needs to be a little bigger than
the actor who takes him on at least at
first you could grow with Zorro and have
that be your big profile main role but I
also feel like if they're gonna recast
him don't go with someone who's just
gonna distract us the whole way but I'd
be down for another Zoro movie don't get
me wrong do it I want it but if Zorro
the mantle were to be passed down who do
you think deserves it I really like your
pick for solo I think that's a great
pick uh guys leave a like subscribe
click that notification Bell and hey
let's shout out some Johnny and Clyde
Roberto Engelman humperdink Tyler Durden
Zachary Bob Barker Irfan clam chowder
Taki lick the snack it's the store Takis
yeah love Simon
Songhai Donald Danny Glover The
Adventures of Pluto Nash
Riley Reed
adult Entertainer NBA
fun dip soda pop
again lanceburg Kiara Bloom Eric
comic-con's 39 Asian name Nick whoa whoa
whoa to racy for you two have to comment
down John Longoria holy Gail Ferguson
Muhammad alright all right all right all
right James won jumping off a cliff and
surviving Rodriguez Alex theater day
passes just for you thank you guys for
being part of our patreon page your
support is not overlooked you sons of
bees hope to see you next month happy
holidays this Thanksgiving we're
grateful for all of you
[Music]